.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: JOINING US NOW IS
VICTOR DAVIS HANSON AND
STEPHEN MILLER FORMER SENIOR
ADVISOR TO
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP FOUNDER
OF AMERICA FIRST LEGAL STEPHEN
SO THE UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS IN
BRUSSELS APPARENTLY WANT TO
DICTATE HOW GOVERNMENTS ARE
ELECTED, HOW THE PEOPLE I GUESS
VOTE AND CHOOSE AND HOW THEY ARE
RUN AND THIS OF THE CROWD
CORRECT?
>> THE ARE THE STEALTH SELF
STYLE PRO-DEMOCRACY CROWD BUT IN
TRUTH THEY HATE AND LOATHE
DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY THEY ARE
SO OUTRAGED THAT A PATRIOTIC
PRO-FAMILY PRIME MINISTER WHO
WAS WON IN ITALY AND THUS THE
REASON WHY THE UNELECTED AND
DEEP STATE IN THE UNELECTED
PROSECUTORS AND DOJ VESTA GATORS
HAS SPENT SIX YEARS GOING AFTER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE
WITH A HATE THE MOST IS WHEN
VOTERS ARE IN CHARGE OF THEIR
OWN DESTINY THEY BELIEVE, THE
ELITES THEY SEE THE MEDIA, OUR
FINANCIAL SYSTEM, OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT SYSTEM WISCONSIN
DOJ, WHETHER TO TALK ABOUT THE
E.U. IN BRUSSELS.
THEY BELIEVE THAT THEY KNOW
BETTER THAN THE EVERYDAY
ORDINARY WORKING PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE IN BORDERS, FAMILIES,
AND GOD.
>> Laura: I THINK WHEN YOU
LOOK BACK VICTOR EDDIE
DECLARATIONS OF THE DEATH OF
POPULISM YOU WHEN I VICTOR WERE
TALKING ABOUT THIS ON THE RADIO
YEARS AGO THIS IS HOW LONG THE
UPPER PRETTY TEAM THE DEMISE OF
POPULISM.
I THINK WE HAVE TO REMIND PEOPLE
OF WHAT THE SMART WERE SAYING
WATCH.
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BE A MAJOR PARTY
THEY NEED TO REJECT THE WHITE
NATIONALISM, THE POPULISM.
>> HOW THE WAGES ELECTIONS MOVE
AHEAD IF YOU'RE TRYING TO PUSH
PEOPLE OUT FOR REJECTING
POPULISM?
[LAUGHS]
I THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT POLITICAL
PARTIES DO?
>> Laura: I FORGOT ABOUT HIM
VICTOR, BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
POPULISM IS GONNA STICK AROUND
AS LONG AS IT KEEPS GOING UP ON
THE ESTABLISHMENT SIDE.
>> OR MAINLY THEY BROUGHT ABOUT
MAY BE MOST RADICAL SHIFT IN
MINORITY VOTING IN RECENT
HISTORY ESPECIALLY IN THE CASE
OF MEXICAN AMERICANS ARE INVOKED
CONSERVATIVELY.
EVERYTHING WE FORGET WAS VERY
CALM AND BY 2019 WE AND HAVE
THIS PROBLEM THESE WERE
DELIVERED THEY THREW STONES
UNTIL COMP ON LAURA YOU'RE NOT
GONNA FLOW BACKUP BY MAGIC FOR
THE MIDTERMS THE REBELS ARE
STILL GOING.
WE DON'T HAVE A BORDER AND IS
NONEXISTENT.
WE SAW IN PHILADELPHIA IS GOOD
TO CONTINUE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
POLICE DETERRENCE ANYMORE.
WE SAY THE SAME THING ABOUT
ENERGY, THE PRICES OF GAS ARE
NOT GOING DOWN.
I JUST PAID $7 A GALLON FOR
DIESEL FUEL YESTERDAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD LOOK ABROAD AND WILL BE
LOST DETERRENCE IN AFGHANISTAN
IS VERY HARD TO RECLAIM THAT
EMPOWER GOING TO EMPOWER CHINA
SO THESE CONSEQUENCES WERE
IDEOLOGICAL THEY WEREN'T DOING A
PLAY THEY DID DELIBERATELY
WHAT'S IRONIC IS ARE WAITING FOR
THE REPUBLICANS TO GRAPHS THAT I
KNOW THEY ARE NATIONALIZING GOD.
468 SOME SEEDS ARE ASKED THESE
CANDIDATES YOU VOTED FOR THE
BORDER.
YOU VOTED FOR THE CRIME, YOU
VOTED FOR THE ENERGY.
YOU VOTED FOR THE INFLATION, YOU
VOTED FOR THE RECESSION.
ARE YOU STILL FOR THAT OR NOT?
I WANT TO KNOW, YES OR NO?
AND THEY ARE KNOCKING A PLAY BY
THE MARKERS OF THESE VARIABLES
THERE TO RUN TOUGH ADS.
THEY BROKE UP THE CYCLE OF MEDIA
NARRATIVE OF JANUARY 6TH, THEN
THE DONALD TRUMP RATE IN JANUARE
AWFUL.
SIMILE DeSANTIS SAID WE ARE
GOING TO DIRECT ATTENTION TO A
REAL ISSUE IMMIGRATION WHICH IS
REALLY WHAT HE DID WITH MARTHA'S
VINEYARD AND THUS DISRUPTED THEM
AND OVERLOOK LOOKING AT THE
ISSUES AGAIN.
THAT IS A LOSE-LOSE SITUATION
AND HE WON'T CHANGE.
WHEN I TALKED ABOUT THAT THAT
ONE ADAPT TO REALITY OR THE
IDEOLOGUES AND FOSSILIZED IN OUR
TIME IS COME AND GONE.
>> Laura: STEPHEN, WE NOTED IN
THE ANGLE ABOUT THE MEDIAS
SESSION WITH COMPARING THE
VICTORY TO THE LIES OF
MUSSOLINI.
THE AP WRITES HOW A OF
NEOFASCIST ROOTS WON BIG IN
ITALY AND THE ATLANTIC ROAD THE
RETURN OF FASCISM IN ITALY.
STEPHEN, IF ANYONE IS
APPROACHING FASCIAS IT IS THE
LEFT TODAY.
THEY WANT TO SHUT DOWN ALL
THOUGHTFUL THINKING ABOUT THESE
VERY DIFFICULT PROBLEMS.
YET THEY DID THE SAME THING TO
DONALD TRUMP TO BEEN NOT?
THEY CALLED HIM AN AUTOCRAT AND
HE WAS A MINI DICTATOR AND HE
WAS CAN START WORLD WAR III THE
SAME PLAYBOOK AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP ARE USING AGAINST
THESE NEW POPULIST LEADERS IN
EUROPE.
>> YES, IT'S THE ONLY PLAYBOOK
THEY HAVE WHICH IS THE DEMONIZE
THEIR OPPONENTS AS FASCIAS AND
BIGOTS, AND RACIST.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
FRIENDS ACROSS EUROPE, THEY ARE
BUYING THE LIES IN THE SMEARS
ANYMORE.
LOOK AT, AS YOU SAID WAS REALLY
FASCIAS HERE?
JOE BIDEN'S DOJ THEY SENT A
S.W.A.T. TEAM THE SENT 30
FEDERAL AGENTS WILL PRO-LIFE
PASTOR'S HOUSE.
REAL COMMONERS, VIOLENT THUGS,
GANG NUMBERS ARE ON THE STREETS
SHOOTING PEOPLE, BEATING THEM,
ASSAULTING THEM, UNDISTURBED,
UNMOLESTED, NO ONE IS EVEN
TOUCHING THEM.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS TRAMPLING
ON OUR BASIC RIGHTS AND FREEDOMS
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT MALONEY,
DONALD TRUMP, OR ANY OTHER
SINGLE HOUSE MEMBER RUNNING OUT
OF THE REPUBLICAN BANNER THIS
YEAR.
THEY ARE GOING TO LABEL ALL OF
THEM AS FASCIAS AND YOU KNOW
WHAT?
THE MORE THEY LIKE, THE MORE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GONNA RISE
UP AND SAY NO.
>> Laura: I THINK IS VICTOR
POINTED OUT ON THE THING